today very special day halflife alex is
out I can't believe it they did it
a halflife game after all these years
that means it's not even fun referencing
the meme obviously you already know
half-life 2 one of my favourite games of
all time and that on the biggest
cliffhanger of all time
I got ballbusting cliffhanger and then
they just didn't make any and here we
are finally with that not number three
but half-life Alex at a prequel made for
VR it seems to me that Valve just I'll
start playing soon I swear it just seems
to me like valve and knew that they're
better off making a really good game
instead of making a half good game even
if they will make a lot of money
nonetheless so the fact that this is out
now it makes me feel like this is gonna
be a really good game especially since I
know Val has been into VR for a long
time and there hasn't been that one VR
game yet out that makes you wanna buy a
head and a VR headset they did not - not
to talk trash on the other VR games
there are good VR games but it hasn't
been like that one and I think this
could be that one I hope I'm right but
who knows there's only one way to find
out
let's freaking play this I hear it's
good already so there we go yeah yeah
yeah yeah so this is the prequel as far
as I'm concerned that's all I understand
that I mentioned have like it is five
years before the collapse of Citadel and
the death of Eli Vance 19 she's 19 I was
thought she was like 26 or something I
I'm not into her anymore I used to like
her ill disgusting oh maybe she's 19 now
of course of course
ayee all right okay
have like - is one of my favorite games
of all time
I [ __ ] love that game holy Shh
I was not ready for that I don't know
how this looks for you guys but holy
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] this is insane dude I've
got I got goosebumps Wow
I haven't even started playing yet look
there's stuff happening everywhere it's
so detailed I pushed a moon so I can go
through stuff some coke push the quick
turn left and right okay
Oh what they're flavored my favorite we
got gelatin ated calorie Pacey
mmm egg flavor you like some egg flavor
that's funny
whoa well done so far this is really
cool all right
press it Eli's calling it's my bed bang
how do they do it if I'm Alex
sorry
so they're building the Citadel that's
SoDo I was actually thinking about
half-life the story the other day can I
draw with these of course I can because
if you think about aliens we always
imagine aliens as if if they're going to
attack us there's gonna be some big war
and they're gonna take us over but the
rule of any war is if you can fight
without a battle that's always the most
effective efficient way to do it so it
would make way more sense that they do
what they do in half-life where it which
is where they sort of manipulate get
into the politician what am I saying
it's just one immolating leaders into
getting what they want instead of
actually having a fight all right
did any of my incoherent rambling make
any sense let me know I just thought it
made I don't know obviously they became
a resistant and all that this is so
amazing oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
so for those of you who are not familiar
with half-life you can see they use
different sort of alien technology
because they they take the best from
other worlds and just steal their
technology which makes sense to which is
a really cool concept
I forgot what they're cold though I
haven't played in a while can I put this
on amazing but what I love about
half-life is just like it's an adventure
from the start to be beginning I need to
stop talking about it I'm sorry it's
just I love it I love it so much now
this is so goddamn cool chair that's
what I said all right what do we got
here this is fun I'm blown away by this
I feel like I'm in the game there's I
totally forgot I was in VR first second
that does not happen out then it's
subtlety that really sells beer very
subtle things
see how I mess that up a little bit took
me out of it so we're in some I guess
Russia maybe Ukraine but I both die
that's work isn't it work doll
go I don't know I don't remember my
parents forced me to study Russian when
I was a kid I thought it was fun though
but I remember anything many affiliates
Roberta you Hey
hey hey hey hey we're good we're good
easy-peasy
sorry let me try and stay in the actual
green screen hey pigeon
okay let's be careful oh my god this
this game might just be it I'm look at
the pitting tonight I wonder how much I
can stretch it no okay no hello finally
a triple-a in beard
uh-oh what are they up to huh sorry Oh
dope hey pigeon stinky Columbine
Columbine what I say combine sorry
how to sign see fail fail you fail about
you made a bad game sorry I got I need
to learn the controls there we go
it looks amazing I gotta say very
impressed I think I made that clear so
far
hey hey guess we go oh oh my god let me
get come on what are you doing you're
crazy okay how do I climb it
woah okay so I just got a whole day okay
that works
where am i I'm so out of it I keep
forgetting I'm in beer
[Music]
I'm gonna shoot some baddies what's
happening over there
I haven't been to Russia or anything
like that I don't really recognize I can
tell it's European obviously how do I
get out of here oh there's a red nice so
you can use different controls I find
like these type of controls makes you
less sick that's funny
[Music]
god damn loading my head my head how
Lord stop moving okay sorry what it's
how did this see
are we gonna see Gordon that'd be so
good he's so hot look how do I escape I
feel like I'm missing something obvious
what am I missing here what is it that
I'm not seeing here I live a drive
I just realized I want to turn on
subtitles for you guys sorry about that
what is this oh it's cigarettes
something else and whatever it is they
gonna kill anybody whose sword and
anybody who knows anybody new sword what
it means off and your dad
Oh
it's a fine fine little cage they got
there okay see what I wicked Higuchi
whoa glad I wasn't on that can I jump on
that
alright so oh my god I was just about to
leave anyway so
[Music]
the drone is fine sorry Oh
comfy cozy oh this is a classy but you
little kids don't know what this is huh
but you never seen one of those before
your kids because you're young you get
it where do I go follow the full little
things usually works not trying to do
that dude you got to hide this better
breath okay
Russell whoa what got dad I know this is
it's just weird which is my plan to give
him back great let's hear it now I'm
ready to take the month my training from
here gets on that train that's it
not necessarily grab something that
represents us fork
grab something that represents us I am
grabbing the fork you don't like the
fork all right
let's are you paying attention that's
cool lady flinch thing yeah I'm gonna
this right oh I'm sorry I'm supposed to
place it well I'm definitely going
before come on porky I believe in you
okay
control me take over the system train
comes to a halt you deal with the
combine situation and we get your dad
sounds good
I can bang bang
what does gravity gums what gravity
gloves
what wow this looks so cool oh my god
this is so cool
how do they make it so precise like what
is it that they did I don't know what it
is they do kind of miss out like I can't
check out Alex that was like half the
fun of that a half life there
come on come on gamers we all know it's
true so already they made a big hand
open how do I aim it with a hand open
[Music]
yeah but how
you said within my hand open oh god I'm
slow whoa okay so that's it I have to
catch it I have to catch it gone
nice nice that's cool that's cool all
right where do I go this is where the
battle begins I got to put on my hat
I'm ready what I did not expect that
that's so funny uh sorry what am I
supposed to go maybe shoot at the lock I
just wasted ammo didn't I
sorry I wasn't really paying attention
to what he said so I don't know where
I'm supposed to go oh here we go so you
have to catch it
sorry I'm gonna be back we're releasing
it over your shot cool I am so up and
ready come on there's gonna be just me
yeah I am ready for this [ __ ]
all right what do we got what do we got
what do we got what have we got but what
a guy
I'm so hype dude I'm such a pretty
little Swedish boy right now
all right yeah yeah it's jammed when the
combine shut down the quarantine zone
the must have tightened security I have
to fight my way out I have a cold guys
our IP
oh my god what I thought the combine
silica qz squeeze it out why why are
they so creepy suck em suck it suck it
suck it you disgusting filthy nasty yeah
get that out of here I probably
shouldn't have done that
Oh what we got down there oh oh oh you
look nasty boy huh will do that to you
girl I keep forgetting I need to catch
it
excuse me sir part of me madam whoa
that's did I grab it by accident I think
I did mrs. stories in your backpack done
yeah barrels right the barrel
what do we have here my wife how does it
working
I twisted her oh I see fair
[Music]
sorry that's my whatsapp everyone no but
that didn't freak you out
why is the door not open today forget
something in the sensual I'm pretty sure
I unlocked it
that's my what's up again I apologize
how do I open is there a button here
hmm oh here we go
oh I see Oh touch something so we have
the power here and then it comes through
uh-huh so we need to there we go oh what
what this is
oh sorry handle I can't listen to simple
instructions pickles I'm sorry
hey listen I'll revenge you man I'll
avenge you man it's gonna be okay man Oh
what is this now oh this is battle time
nailed it
heavy objects with both hands but I have
a gun I'm okay all right we got some
handy Forks and some dandy boys shut up
oh they got the barnacles oh that's
disgusting they're way worse now oh I
need to get the hang of that
what that went smooth yeah well how was
it on the other side no how did that
happen yeah that was so gross
oh there's something up there how and
the nice Oh something here too let's not
mess this up again whoa cool this is so
dope I wish I could kick this yeah
now I don't want to do this oh god I
forgot it that's that Oh buddy you're
next I'm just gonna go in here is there
nothing in here
Oh head oh are you serious I guess I can
jump through here how you doing buddy
yeah
hipster that's what happens don't know
what these are for but I'll take them
amazing
absolutely what a pleasure to be playing
this game isn't that right isn't that
right
isn't that right I say all right shoot
him in the nipple yeah I always wanted
to do that always shoot him in the
nipple all right it looks like we have a
lot of options where to go here that
looks like a dead end so I'm gonna guess
the house
yep yeah yeah looks like that doesn't oh
hello come to poppy what about here
no okay what about over here
it's a lot of these I'm not sure what
they do here these bread nessler I hate
them don't touch them Alex you'll get
burned another one don't know what
you're for they said upgrades and they
know hello hmm not sure where I'm
supposed to go here maybe another one
and another one
I keep circling toilet always go for the
toilet guys yes yes they do
sorry ah hello hello who toilets just
looking oh look at that
Hey look at that getting the hang of it
guys hey hey I could hide in there if
that gets bad alright let's confront
this thing ah come on
yeah well that leaves me found sir
that's people always get mad at me for
not looking around enough dude that one
of these days I mean in a couple minutes
maybe your oh [ __ ] you I'll take that
I'll take that
appreciate it
[ __ ] all right so we're using
the rewiring tool
I assume this is amazing yeah I did it I
did it guys how about this maybe we
should push this we can enter through
the window half-life 2 was one of the
first games I remember at least that
really utilized physics-based puzzles is
that right you like physics-based
puzzles ooh I think a lot of stuff to
half-life data's sort of became the norm
can you get them not the boy hey not the
boy huh
nice jeans [ __ ] all right heavy
objects with both hands I can't believe
I'm doing this
really oh I can't okay okay gun please
dude they're very generous with the ammo
cutter show Herschel everything is
interactive that's a really cool there's
something in here yeah I could see you
glow feel so satisfying they solved that
problem with VR would like taking stuff
off the ground is so annoying they turn
it into something fun that's smart
I'm not going to hurt you my little
child what's your name Bernie Bernie
Bernie Bernie Bernie I will never hurt
you
tickle tickle you're beautiful people
don't I will come out I will release you
I will come back one day and I will oh
no I forgot you did that oh my god I'm
so sorry Bernice money you would do the
same for me yeah we're cool
recall I come back for you this is so
cool I'm never expecting to rack with
one of these can imagine when you play
this first time I like Oh in the future
what oh my god that's the thing I told
you about they take other where am i I'm
so lost I wish I had a better team set
up it's like they took what is this I
don't have anything to put there except
my dear my Alex fat come on what is
happening
I need to start paying attention more
I'm just so that looks like her mm-hmm
did I miss something
is it possible I miss something
oh they got the shield as well or in
thesis shields I don't remember so what
is this this is something else why I'm
sorry what know that lose this thing
okay so this is the lock and this is the
key so my goal it's to get the thing to
the thing my god my brain is huge I know
I know guys I know that's ironic I mean
it's not funny
Wow
oh my god dude what's wrong with this
country
all right which one no press so this one
is connected this one is not so maybe I
have to align them or something yeah oh
my oh my god that is so disturbing oh my
god oh my god
Oh No
holy cow this is insane dude hey we're
going after our dad again I hid wherever
I heard that before
am I still wearing the Hat I'll come
back for you
Bernice Marie I'm really creative with
names Ernie
that wasn't there before
oh yeah we open the gate min me holy
[ __ ] this is so cool
Sam Alex
so hey little had a similar theme I feel
like we like zombies and aliens and
you're in between us human I wonder who
took from who it must have been halos
ceiling right maybe you know get this is
absolutely insane did Oh Oh it's loading
all right so that's the city huh that's
so cool I bet they have the whole thing
mapped out
this is amazing what a time to be a
gamer guys supply craves I'm not even
mad about half-life 3 anymore that's oh
this better not being store items in
wrist pockets what cool all right I'm
gonna be careful with this one I'm gonna
go ahead and place this one here and not
blow it up barrel piggie barrel yeah
barrels oh god oh dude Ravenholm do you
guys remember how [ __ ] scary that was
that was such a classic episodic part of
a video game
anyone that's played half-life to know
exactly what I'm talking about
was it Raven home I don't remember
should I let him in and then he'll he'll
go on the thing right
come I come I come I come I come to me
bound by ash hey Einstein I'm on your
side oh let's be careful kids you get
that I said that perfectly and you know
it alright we'll use the cardboard hey
gloves hey hey look I'm I'm a different
game now I'm just gonna I'm just no yeah
alright hat hats on gamers how did I
hell how the hell did I put that I can't
claim its consumer excuse my pad on me
mmm Oh [ __ ] yeah Oh Oh careful
there did I take some damage say no I
gotta get good at reloading if I'm gonna
be good at this game
here's a tricky one because I can't
ill oh my god it has a special treat it
has a spine give it ow this could be a
trap what what Stacy what's the [ __ ]
problem huh oh I see
when skid-row
hey can I put on the Hat or one yeah and
now I'm ready I ran mother buggers yeah
open
konnichiwa me my son
oh hi yo gozaimasu
[ __ ] that's right
it's alright it's alright I thought
there was someone behind me either way
that's why I didn't back up we're good
on life yeah I need to start getting
better at this the headcrabs are so cute
still no no no this is the most
important part of the game come on yeah
all right sniper shot or should I wait
for the other guy I'll just do this how
you doing there buddy you're right
all right back up oh they can throw
something I forgot they cool so cool you
all right there mate you're all right
there little bit of a lap yeah
never vagina I knew it yeah that's
disgusting thanks for reminding me we'll
be fine
why it's so sad man but oh wow oh he
didn't think so I got this oriented
he'll come to puppy people will be
popping Skippy really popping well
that's what I'm talking about
no one asked I don't think that's good
out first thing I thought they were
generous and that was good part of this
okay hello thank you what an epic gamer
yeah I'm in Edo alright let's be a
stealth be here let's let's be smart
about this
I just mess everything up tonight uh-huh
uh-huh excuse me where do I go
is it me or is it milk mihalick
completely glitched Jesus
freaking mothers licking finger-licking
today's Christians BP in my kitchen
where to go where to go
don't you dare [ __ ] I don't have
anymore mo this is problem for me you
know alright what's happening I was
loading guess I can't jump around like
crazy
hopefully the headcrab do spawns I need
to look around for a more more I know it
I don't have em Oh Oh God give me ammo
we see can you give me like something to
kill them win
there you go Jesus
oh I can go off this so sexy I'm [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah come on come on fish
is it good oh god all right I I don't
want to kill you man I don't want to
kill you me don't make me do it you're
such a doofus don't ever don't ever do
that again the attitude of some people
huh I'm trying to help him get off the
streets man
trying to make him be somebody Oh
straight from the dick nice I need to
look for more ammo we already looked
here the search that's the word yeah it
is the word Felix all right come on come
on [ __ ]
[ __ ] my teddy bishop oh that's
never knew okay I have not seen this
before have you
seeing this possibly using [ __ ]
garbage
yep it's just
oh my god that's not I'm it's looking at
me
hey hey that's normal happens every day
come on on board
give me ammo all right make me an ammo
mr. cardboard alien keep finding those
all right sorry I know it's such a party
pooper
you better not move with haha oh whoa
sooo gay sooo gay 'no oh my god oh my
god so cool
whoa it's the freemen it's the story of
the freemen you see it's the freemen all
someone spent a lot of time on this
worth the gown smart the guns might be
bigger baby they beep it about yes this
is this is fine art that they didn't
hear you can see the line work it's very
good vortigaunts Martha gone well go
ahead cardboard do your thing cardboard
Wow Sugoi a cardboard son you look so
good so good cutter what this one it's
it this beautiful I got a look at it
from a specific angle don't I
[Music]
boom sky boom ba-doom
No uh-oh there's a puzzle I didn't
notice because there was dots right we
got dots here huh yeah yeah so there's
only two combinations of buttons what I
shall do
it's to combinational buttons oh I see
it I see it so there's many options
there's could that be it right
how do I know which one is the right one
okay I'll try that one all right that
work gamers I'm gonna end part one here
all right gamers that was an absolute
privilege to play if you want to see one
another so tomorrow smash like and I'll
make sure to do another one and I'll see
you then have fun for them bye bye